The saltwater crocodile is
among the fiercest hunters
on the planet.
This awe-inspiring
prehistoric predator
has the strongest animal
bite ever recorded
and can measure 20 feet long.
No doubt it takes a
certain breed of human
to live in the salty's habitat.
But in Australia's
top end, locals
have a unique and surprising
method to cope with the world's
largest reptile.
Here's Tim Samuel's,
"Down Under."
[music playing]
[birds chriping]
[snorting]
'It's rare these days
to be able to celebrate
an extinction good news story.
But 40 odd years after
being close to disappearing,
crocodiles now outnumber humans
in the Northern Territory
thanks to an aggressive
conservation campaign.
As the humans around here
push their boundaries,
the crocodile
population pushes back.
Keeping the peace is
a constant struggle.
[music playing]
REPORTER: Good evening.
A family's worst
nightmare has come true
with strong indications
their 11-year-old girl
has been taken by a crocodile.
Charlene O'Sullivan's
daughter, Brioni,
went swimming with
her sister and a group
of friends Lambells Lagoon.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS: In 2009,
Charlene O'Sullivan's
11-year-old daughter,
Brioni, became
the 64th recorded
Australian to be killed
by a saltwater crocodile.
I just remember sitting there
numb, thinking what happened?
TIM SAMUELS: This
is where Brioni
was swimming with her
seven-year-old sister
Beth and two friends.
I saw a crocodile tail
splash the surface,
and she disappeared.
[music playing]
What was your
emotional reaction?
Angry, betrayed.
Did anybody else know that there
were crocodiles in the area?
And if they did, why
didn't they tell us?
[music playing]
This is my favorite.
Yeah, that's her.
How often does Brioni
pop into your mind?
Daily.
And I am richer for having her,
even if it was for a moment.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS:
Saltwater crocodiles
are like living dinosaurs.
With adult males averaging
a size of 17 feet
and weighing half a ton
that a terrifying predator,
so much so that for
a long time killing
them was a badge of honor.
In fact, by the 1970s,
trophy hunting nearly
wiped them out altogether.
But 40 years ago, a
controversial conservation plan
brought them back
from the brink.
Ironically, it was so
successful that now it's
Aussies that feel under threat.
So what convinced the folks
in the Northern Territory,
the so-called "Top End," to live
alongside these deadly beasts?
Behind this whole
conservation effort
is one guy, a Darwin
zoologist, the godfather
of crocodile conservation.
Grahame Webb knows
Crocs are a tough sell.
Crocs are as bad as they look.
They will rip your arms
off, your legs off,
they'll eat your children.
You've got to have
good incentives
for people to put up with that.
TIM SAMUELS: We met Grahame at
Crocodylus Park, the Wildlife
Center he founded in 1994.
I feel like a maternity nurse.
Yeah.
TIM SAMUELS: Grahame's
been advocating
for saltwater crocodiles,
or salty's, since the 70s.
But his approach
was and is divisive.
His aim is to get locals
to see the creature
not so much as a killer,
but a profitable commodity.
Take these eggs.
These were laid by
the crocs at the park.
Grahame and his
team have taken them
to sell to commercial farmers
to raise for slaughter.
What's their fate?
Their fate is they'll
go in the incubator,
and then they'll go
into a farm somewhere.
On the farm raises them to
turn them into leather goods?
Leather goods, and they go
into meat and souvenirs and
belts and all sorts of things.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS: Favored by luxury
brands like Louis Vuitton
and Gucci, crocodile
leather fetches up to 30
times the price of cow leather.
Some URMA handbags go for
well over 100,000 US dollars.
[music playing]
All told, Aussie salty's are
$100 million US dollar a year
industry, and that's
a strong motivation
for keeping croc numbers up.
Does it not feel
strange that you are--
Not for me.
A zoologist, you're
a conservationist,
you're lovingly
rearing these eggs
to then turn into a handbag.
I can look at what
we've achieved here.
We've brought the populations
back to carrying capacity.
TIM SAMUELS: Grahame
compares salty's
with another deadly predator
fighting for survival.
Back in the 70s,
the global number
of wild tigers was roughly
the same as the number
of top end salty's.
Today, the crocs
have bounced back,
but the tiger
remains on the brink.
Why is that?
That's because the people
who live with tigers
do not have any vested interest
in having lots of tigers.
TIM SAMUELS: Though the
hatchlings from these eggs
will grow up on
farms, there are still
100,000 salty's roaming in the
wild in the Northern Territory.
So while trophy
hunting is banned,
the Aussie government
allows up to 1,200 permits
a year to top end hunters
who track down problem crocs.
[knife sharpening]
I'm all ready to go
for a bit of a recky.
When you say recky,
do you mean see
if any crocodiles is out there?
- Yes.
And if there is, we're
going to catch them.
Right.
Great.
Roger Matthews
makes a living culling
problem crocs with the help
of his teenage son, Brody.
Are you game fro
a a bit of action?
Yeah, let's see
what's out there.
[music playing]
Roger is being called
out to this ranch
to hunt down a croc that's
been stalking the owner's cows.
[music playing]
We drive to a nearby
waterhole, a place
salty's are known to hide out.
You'd be surprised,
half a meter of water
and this huge crocodile.
TIM SAMUELS: The salty's MO
is to ambush their victims
and drag them into the
water and drown them.
[roaring]
You see this?
This is definitely a crocodile.
A few bubbles in here.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS: And how do you
know there's just one in there?
You don't.
Air bubbles and the nose.
See that?
TIM SAMUELS: Yeah.
Roger has spotted the salty.
Now the hard part--
it's pretty wild.
Catching it.
A two man job.
Woah.
Reeling in a croc like this
is a half ton tug-of-war.
Have you got it?
ROGER MATTHEWS: We got him.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUES: By law, this croc
must be humanely put down.
OK.
Do you feel bad about
having to do this?
ROGER MATTHEWS: I do, but
also it's what we have to do.
TIM SAMUELS: And
how he gets paid.
And how much is a
nice trophy skin?
A full meter
crocodile, the skin
could be worth anywhere
from $5,000 to $6,000.
And the skull is about
$4,000 Australian dollars.
TIM SAMUELS: Roger
loves crocs, yet,
he makes a living hunting them.
It's contradictions like
these that define Australia's
croc conservation program.
Consider Charlene O'Sullivan.
Her daughter, Brioni, was
killed by a croc in 2009.
Now, she farms them.
Are you serious?
I'm absolutely serious.
Not what a lot of
people expected.
They're just over here.
TIM SAMUELS: How many
crocodiles do you have?
CHARLENE O'SULLIVAN:
About 4,500 at the moment.
TIM SAMUELS: Charlen's
farm is called be BA Crocs.
The BA stands for Brioni Anne.
[music playing]
It is, I guess, the legacy
towards my daughter's death,
to her life as well.
This is for her.
[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS: In a
capitalistic society,
it seems everything can be
sold, given the right price,
even animal conservation.
That salty's are no
longer endangered
is proof for many this
commercial model is working.
But as stories of
commercial conservation
play out around the world
on game reserves in Africa
and the jungles
of Southeast Asia,
the true costs
remain to be seen.